personally Mass Effect means a lot to me
like we say we when when we create
something we put it out it is like you
know putting your own child out there
right that feeling still exists I mean
eventually I'll move on to another IP
I'm sure eventually and I had the choice
even previous to this right but but for
now Mass Effect it's it's too special to
me and it's too important I think to to
RPG errors in the gaming community I
mean who wouldn't take that opportunity
to do that right
[Music]
there are a few franchises that have
been able to leave a footprint on the
culture of videogames as prominent as
Mass Effect has the original trilogy
reveled in meticulous details depicting
fascinating alien cultures political
strife and interspecies tensions with
complex and memorable characters driving
the narrative for a generation of gamers
like me
Mass Effect is our Star Trek it's our
Doctor Who our Star Wars but as with all
major fandoms Mass Effect is not without
its controversies the original trilogy
was built on choice and consequence it
promised players that each of their
actions however big or small would have
ramifications on the outcome of the
story and across three games spanning
over a hundred hours it lived up to that
promise right up until its final moments
in Mass Effect 3 as the curtains drew to
a close and players took the final steps
on their journey the game jettisoned the
characterization and storytelling
nuances that it defined the series for
some fans these final moments have
marked the legacy of the series as
strongly as everything Bioware achieved
in the hours preceding them but now with
Mass Effect Andromeda the studio is
leaving Commander Shepard and the Milky
Way behind for both the characters in
the game and the people making it
andromeda is about venturing into the
unfamiliar in hopes of finding a new
beginning in this two-part series
looking at the development of Mass
Effect Andromeda we traveled to PAX East
in Boston just days before the game's
launch where we talked to by hour about
the series and its newest entry in
episode 1 we're going to look at the
impact of the original trilogy and the
controversy surrounding its ending
before delving into the future Bioware
hopes to build for the series in Episode
two this is the story of Mass Effect
Andromeda
[Music]
[Music]
Mass Effect launched in 2007 a year
filled with landmark titles the
influence of which are still seen in the
games of today it was a year in which
Call of Duty 4 redefined first-person
shooters for the modern age bioshock
enraptured us with a thought-provoking
commentary on player agency and Nintendo
reminded us of the pure joy gaming can
inspire with Super Mario Galaxy
so yeah 2007 was a momentous year with
the sheer brilliance of these
blockbusters dwarfing all but the most
groundbreaking releases and amongst it
all there was one title that really
stood out from the crowd it was a game
that while not perfect showed immense
ambition it blurred genre lines by
marrying deep role-playing with
third-person shooting to create an
experience that felt steeped in history
but was also forward-thinking but beyond
that it delivered an intricate sci-fi
universe on a scale that had previously
only been seen in PC MMOs and it did so
with uncompromising attention to detail
the first Mass Effect laid the
foundations for Bioware's narrative
aspirations establishing alien races
exploring their cultures and
interweaving complex political tensions
between them it was a game that invited
players to connect with characters on a
human level to learn about their history
their hopes their fears and consider
them throughout the investment people
had in these characters was leveraged
for emotionally charged moments in which
decisions could decide the fate of a
friend or even the future of a species
Mass Effect promoted choice to ensure
players felt they weren't just
experiencing a story but were writing
their own well building on this scale
and characterization of this nuanced or
perhaps the most enduring part of its
legacy for me and thousands of others
each Mass Effect games stirred a
childlike wonder the type that pierces
through reality to make you believe in
Hogwarts the force or the plight of the
Browncoats and for the people working on
Andromeda many of which joined Bioware
as fans and are newcomers to developing
Mass Effect it was no different
so I bought mass one on launch day and
you know I had always wanted a a massive
space opera type RPG to play it changed
how I looked at sci-fi videogames the
the amount of inspiration that I drew
from being able to meet all these new a
lien for the first time in a galaxy I
think was was awesome that was the major
thing really feeling like you were
telling a human story but in this brand
new area of all these different species
I had never met before
he kind of evoked a lot of the feelings
I had with Star Wars and properties like
that before the scale was definitely
impressive like not just the physical
scale the amount of places you could go
although yes that was cool too but the
sense of like no this is a whole galaxy
you can actually explore that that has
been around awhile and like you have an
important part to play but this universe
exists without you it has its own
history and characters have new thing
going on and I like that even if you
remember the intro to Mass Effect 1 at
the beginning you're a big deal in your
own right but you're not you're not do
the Grand High king of everything like
no you're second someone else is captain
to the ship the beginning I thought that
was really cool so I was sick the
weekend I picked up anyone played it two
days picked up one disc put me2 in and
just kept going so it very quickly
consumed me the fascination with it and
it just it really changed the way I
viewed games also as a player you know
being like oh I'll try something new and
then realizing wow this is an experience
in games I'd never previously you know
engaged with probably the one of the
more powerful moments to me if I
remember correctly it was the moment
with Legion when he you could either
choose whether he would die or I think
it was tally would die and that to me
was gut-wrenching because both of those
characters I'd loved and I remember
playing it through the one time and then
I think Legion died and like no no no no
no no no no this is wrong and then go
back load the save again play it through
then tally died the next time I'm like I
can't do it
That moment when
you can actually explore the inside of
the world the kind of gate at the
beginning and suddenly you land with
your Clemson Megu and you go around but
it doesn't matter the execution doesn't
matter because it awakes something in
you about the sheer diversity and
discovering but you realize after when
you keep playing a trilogy that that
feeling of curiosity the world to
discover actually applies to people to
the other character and this is what my
cific to explore etc and and this is so
for me the definition of mass effect as
a personal level starts there that
little childhood sparkled that solar
lights in you and say oh I just want to
explore it and then you want to explore
reiationship and then you want to
explore something
[Music]
but the Mass Effect series is not
without its flaws and for some the
concluding chapter of the trilogy
brought the series to an unsatisfactory
close
players had poured themselves into the
series and charted a path for the
narrative that felt unique and personal
to them they made the universe their own
but in its final moments their impact
felt diminished Bioware faced a
difficult challenge to finish the
trilogy it needed to exert its own
authorship over a narrative that until
then had largely been guided by player
decisions and in doing so it had to wrap
up the trilogy in a way that accounted
for all those decisions arguably an
impossible task
Bioware solution was to offer three
resolutions that together provided an
end to the broader narrative but failed
to properly pay off the many
relationships players had cultivated
over the series the response to the
ending was resounding with aggrieved
fans letting Bioware know of their
displeasure through various grassroots
movements and social networks it was a
lot of pressure on us and we put a lot
of time and love into tying off those
story threads but you never know right
you never know what what we think is is
like oh that's that's gonna nail it
that's gonna be awesome everyone's gonna
love this some people might not and you
don't really know until you put the game
out as we've seen in the past you know
we generate a lot of passion of our
friends and ultimately you need to take
that as a reward I people care about
what you do but you need to accept that
passion goes both ways
it really felt like it ended like I said
you know had the ending you know gone
off a little bit more smoothly I think
we would have really personally
emotionally had that closure a bit more
but as far as saying goodbye to the
characters in the world I'd kind of
already done that I felt like I've done
that through the process of just putting
that out there and developing it right
oh we weren't happy we weren't happy
because this this was our baby as much
as it was anyone else's right wanting to
send it off and make it you know
the satisfying thing that people wanted
but as time went on and as things died
down a little bit and we look back and
we continued with some of the DLC in the
Citadel we're still very very proud of
it we're still very happy with what we
did and I think it set the stage for the
future because it it formalized for us
that Shepherd story was done and that we
told all we wanted to tell in that
universe so it kind of prompted us to
look forward and say ok well what's next
one aspect in light of the controversy
the studio released the extended cut DLC
to address some of the plot holes fans
raised as problematic and explore the
aftermath of the final decision further
but by this time fan sentiment had
solidified this outcry of disappointment
shifted the focus away from what Mass
Effect 3 and the series had achieved
across three games the discussion became
fixated on the broad strokes that
outlined the narrative instead of the
finer details that colored it to quote
GameSpot's review Mass Effect 3 was a
game about saving the galaxy but a
galaxy is just a thing an idea an
abstract a meaningless collection of
plutinos planets and pulsars Mass Effect
is actually about saving people and
there's a big difference there
that difference was buried under the
controversy and like it or not it's the
starting point for Andromeda six hundred
years after that fateful conversation
with the catalyst mass effect is moving
on from Shepherd beyond the Milky Way
and the characters and stories that were
contained within it for the people that
created and shepherded the original
trilogy to its conclusion Andromeda is a
second attempt at realizing ambitions
that fell to the wayside the first time
around the interesting thing is this is
that as that you know Mass Effect
Andromeda even though it's the fourth in
the series is really like I said I've
said it several times it's a new start
but it was a new start on a new engine
it's a new console cycle it's a new team
and so more so than any of the games
since Mass Effect one this one feels
like it's got all those things that we
wish we could have done because we were
really doing them for the first time but
what ended up happening is that living
up to Mass Effect does not make things
easier alright so yes it's well-defined
but also we wanted of course to you know
moving some Gemini bringing new races
and everything but it's the constant
reminder that Mass Effect means
something to the fans and as much as you
want to move that game forward if you
don't deliver what people expect in the
Mass Effect game it doesn't matter for
me as much as it's a a constant pressure
on us it's a good pressure that keeps us
going and that's where I take my energy
so so my experience with Mass Effect is
less about the game itself and more
about what it means for so many people
and how that translates into our fuel if
you're not right it's like if you go to
the pack show floor tomorrow you will
see tons of Mass Effect cosplay you will
see hundreds of people who care
desperately about the franchise most
other developers can't say that they
have them
magic like that built into their fanbase
so they kind of lift us up right it's
it's them who make the possible the
possibilities for the future it's not
you know uh sir
[Music]
while the old guard ensures that my soul
of mass effect is enshrined it's
Bioware's new blood that is attempting
to redefine its identity for a new
generation
[Music]
fans are at the heart of mass effect and
in Episode two of this series we'll be
talking to the developers that admired
the franchise from the outside but who
are now charting its future from within
[Music]
you
[Music]